大家好,下面我来给大家介绍一下在店群模式下怎样复制商品,在之前的视频里面我们已经设置好了这些店群,这里有一个主店和一个分店,接下来我们是用主店来操作来进行商品的复制,点击这个菜单,然后进来之后可以看到有这么几个标签,这些是菜单我们首先点这个地方,然后来添加一条复制的规则。
名字可以随便写,然后在这里您可以进行一些自定义的个性化的设置,也可以不够选,我们可以选一个直接上架或者这个不复制手机端的描述,然后这个呢特别说明一下,这个人实时同步,如果您复制之后的话想在这两个商品,
之间呢开启这个实时同步一些数据的话,需要把这个打开,比如说您这个复制之后在两个店之间,这两个商品之间有实时的同步库存的标准的价格编码什么,您就需要把这个打开,
我们暂时先不开这个,先来试一下,您确定把这个规则复制的规则先创建好了,您在这里的话,您可以随时去查看这个规则,
然后进行编辑,或者说删除,进行一些操作,那现在规则设置好了,来看,来到这个商品这里。
在这个地方有些素素的条件,可以看到这里有个圆店铺,就是我要把哪个店铺的商品去复制出去呢。
这里店铺一是主店,店铺二是分店,您可以选择任一个店铺作为源头的这个商品的存在的店铺。
我们比如说我们就用源头就用这个主店来复制,那这样来我们来试一下,下面显示的都是主店的这些商品。
我们来找一个来试一下,比如说把这个要复制出去,这里有立即复制和定时复制。
先看定时复制的话,这里是您最终的话是有一个时间的选择,先来看这一步。
这里可以选择的是目标店铺,您要把刚才选在主店的这个商品复制到哪里来。
比如说我们要把它复制到这个分店二,这个地方。选择的就是刚才这个复制的规则,然后您要给它选一个分类,比如说随便选一个分类。
然后运费模板,您可以选择一个,也可以选择复制原商品的运费模板,或者您选一个自己已经存在的运费模板都可以。
然后这些都选好,比如说您点确定,那这里的话您可以选择一个时间,您希望在几月几号几点去开始这个复制。
这是定时复制,那我们要测销回来,如果您想马上去复制,也可以用这个连立即复制。
当然这个下了框子里是有一些选项的,首先您可以对选中的这些商品进行复制,也可以对这边所有查出来的工32个这个商品,批量的复制。
当然也可以直接把出售中或者仓库中或者全店复制,全店复制就用最后这个,把它全部复制过去,这样都是可以选的。
我们先直接用第一个,这里的话还像刚才一样,我们选择分店,选择这个,然后这里随便选一个。
好,这里,下面我们来点确定,这里显示提交成功了,提交成功的话,我们可以到这里来查看一下。
查看这个复制任务,可以看到这条任务,复制任务正在处理,商品总数是一个,要复制一个。
我们可以稍等下就点,再查询一下看看。这里是不需要您在这里一直等的,其实您也可以把这个浏览器关掉或者去干掉别的事,都是可以的,这是一个离线的复制,是不会受到影响的。
好了,我们可以看到,现在是已完成状态,成功了一条,就说明这条已经复制成功了。我们可以点这个任务ID,直接跳过去,来看这个复制的记录。
原商品是来自一个店,目标的店铺,给你复制好的这个商品的ID是多少,然后这个商品,包括它里面复制里面有多少个图片,它的状态或是实践,这些都是有的,你可以点这个图片,直接就跳到这个商品。
在这里的话,还有两个按钮,您可以导出来这个复制的记录,如果说您这个复制是失败的,您也可以在这里比如说,某一批的复制有一些失败,您可以直接把失败的查询出来,然后点这个重新复制,这就可以把这些失败的这些直接重新复制一次。
这些都是可以比较方便的一些操作。这里有个小技巧,就是在是否已复制这里,您可以看这里有个搜索条件,刚才可以看到我们在给这个测试店铺二已经复制了一个,我们来搜索一下,看看它能不能搜索了。
好了,您可以看到,这就是显示了刚才我们已经复制的这一条,但是如果您第一次复制了一批商品,那接下来您再复制的话,想把这些过滤掉。
已经复制的就不再显示了,那我们可以,您可以选择这个,选择店铺二为复制。
这次查出来的,就会把那个已经复制的过滤掉,在剩下的这些都是没复制的。这个复制商品就给大家介绍到这里。谢谢。